welcome back we here in the Ingraham
angle have been hearing that there might
soon be a major announcement about the
Hillary Clinton email investigation on
Capitol Hill joining us now from
Tallahassee Florida is someone who might
have a thing or two to do with that
congressman Matt Gaetz a Republican from
Florida congressman you can't tease us
and give us nothing here tonight okay
if there's something going on my ears
have been filled up with all sorts of
whispers all day today about something
involving a special designation for the
Hillary Clinton email investigation over
at the FBI and that is raising questions
what can you tell us tonight and if you
say you can't talk about it we're gonna
have to go talk about David Cassidy
again for another segment yeah well we
absolutely could talk about it Laura I
am immediately calling for an
investigation into the special treatment
that the FBI gave Hillary Clinton and
particularly in this email scandal in
late October right before the election
emails were sent by now the Deputy
Director of the FBI Andrew McCabe where
McCabe said that the Hillary
investigation would be given special
status that it would not go through the
normal investigative procedures that
would typically append to this type of
an investigation
he told others at the FBI that there
would be a small team at headquarters
that would make the decisions and
conduct the investigation walling off
others who might have discovered
information or brought additional facts
to light linked this to the information
we have about James Comey drafting the
exoneration statement of Hillary Clinton
before she was even interviewed before
other key witnesses were interviewed so
now we have absolute proof of what
you've been saying for a long time Laura
and that's that Hillary Clinton was
treated differently than any other
American would be treated and as a
member of the Judiciary Committee I want
answers from the FBI about how we can
stop this type of special treatment for
politicians in the future now we've been
talking about the special treatment that
politicians get when it comes to issues
of harassment other types of
discrimination
with that shush fun slush fund on
Capitol Hill seventeen million dollars
paid out to victims all confidential
that's just an absolute outrage but in
this case we're talking about the former
Secretary of State she's running for
president as a white-hot spotlight on
her and on this question of her emails
though not ones that were destroyed the
intent to set up that private server
when something is designated as special
investigation one could hear that and
say there's going to be more scrutiny
placed on the subject but you're saying
when it's special it means skirting
normal channels is that is that what you
can confirm to us tonight
well Laura we have to look at all the
evidence in context here you have Mr
McCabe telling others at the FBI that
this won't be handled like other
investigations that it will be a small
team at headquarters the reason that's
so troubling is that we've learned as a
consequence of testimony before the
Senate that James Comey leading that
investigation it drafted the exoneration
statement essentially rendered the
verdict on the Hillary Clinton email
scandal before even conducting the
investigation now we've got these McCabe
emails that show that others were not
allowed to participate that they were
expressly excluded even more damning
context is the fact that these emails
also reveal that McCabe was dealing with
his own scandal because he was involved
with his wife's political campaign
funded by the Clintons and their allies
and that's not the type of FBI we need
we need the type of checks and balances
at the FBI where people get equal
treatment under the law we don't have
that in a circumstance where you've got
special treatment for someone like
Hillary Clinton and then you've got an
exoneration statement before you even
have the investigation concluded I think
we're gonna be learning a lot more about
Andrew McCabe in the coming weeks and
you can't you can't mix politics in the
FBI you're not supposed to and so his
wife was running for Virginia Senate a
lot of questions remaining about him and
call me together and we appreciate it
Happy Thanksgiving congressman and you
can give us more information next week
we want all the interim
next week's doing all the document
requests we went all all the memos to
the file that Jim called me did in the
back of a sedan we want all those